So for this I'm going to want you guys to fill in the chart that I'm about to
make. Now first, we know that our Nervous System is divided into two main
areas. One, that deals with our outside body. An the other that's responsible
for our brain an spinal cord. Then we further divide this system into two more.
One that deals with sensory information and one that deals with our involuntary
systems. We divide the involuntary system into the Sympathetic and the
Parasympathetic. One of these systems brings us back to normal and the other
system is responsible for the flight or fight response. Here are your options,
the Somatic Nervous System, back to normal, Central Nervous System, Autonomic
Nervous System, fight or flight, Peripheral Nervous System. Type in the answers
in these blanks.